we begin this morning with the shutdown
of the federal government the government
stopped operating at midnight halting
all but essential services this after
the Senate came ten votes short of
reaching a temporary last-minute funding
deal that would have kept the government
open through February 16th it comes on
the anniversary of president Trump's
inauguration and with the GOP in control
of both chambers of Congress and the
White House it is a first in history the
president is placing blame on Senate
Democrats however five Democrats broke
with their party to back the measure
while five Republicans voted against it
Democrats were holding out for a
comprehensive bill and a deal to protect
daca recipients immigrants brought to
the US illegally as children Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where
lawmakers were still trying to cut a
deal early this morning Nancy good
morning good morning burning the
midnight oil indeed and if Republican
leaders get their way this shutdown will
not last long they are hoping that
Democrats join them later today in
passing a bill to keep the government
open for just two and a half weeks they
say that should give them enough time to
craft a compromise providing legal
status to those so-called dreamers the
motion is not agreed to
the GOP bill to fund the government
failed on the Senate floor just before
midnight the government shutdown was
100% avoidable government functions
began scaling back at 12:01 a.m. as the
Senate's Republican leader fumed held
all his hostage all of it hostage over
the completely unrelated issue of
illegal immigration Democrats were
demanding a deal granting legal status
to immigrants brought to this country
illegally as children without it all but
five Senate Democrats made good on their
threat to bring down a bill funding the
government for one month
mr. Carper no last-ditch negotiations to
head off a shutdown went nowhere this
will be called the Trump shut down
Democratic leader Chuck Schumer's
he thought he and the president made
progress on a deal when they met at the
White House Friday but by the afternoon
he said the president pulled back at the
urging of conservatives even though
President Trump seemed to like an
outline of a deal in the room he did not
press his party in Congress to accept it
what happened to the president Trump who
asked us to come up with a deal leader
McConnell is now proposing a bill to
fund the government through February 8th
which Republican Lindsey Graham had
suggested would give the two sides just
enough time to craft a dreamer deal in
earnest and there will be no deal
without a daca solution the Senate is
coming back in at noon eastern time they
have not set a time for a vote the house
would have to take a vote as well but
even if they buy themselves another two
and a half weeks Alex this is an issue
that has stymied Congress for years so
there's no guarantee that another two
and a half weeks will necessarily make
the difference Nancy Cordes burning that
midnight oil herself right on Capitol
Hill thanks Nancy
you're welcome